Les mecs qui font les pubs à la télé :
soit ils sont completement drogués,
soit ils viennent
d'un monde parrallèle.
Je vois que ça !
Je crois que les pubs, c'est le truc
le plus éloigné de la réalité.
Non ?
Bonjour,
je suis votre nouvelle voisine
On s'est vus l'autre jour...
Ah oui, c'est vrai.
Ah..
je vois que vous avez euh...
Un peu de gâteau ?
Il est délicieux !
Non merci. Je crois que
c'est un peu trop pour moi.
Je crois que je préfèrerai le...
Mais sortez de chez moi !
Je crois que je préfèrerai le Kin...
OH, DEGAGE !
OU J'APPELLE LES FLICS !!
Non, je veux un Kinder B...
(Ils s'embrouillent)
Excusez-moi... Pensez-vous que
vos dents sont vraiment propre ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Vérifions ça.
(Cyprien)
Regardez.
Des bactéries ?
Mais je me suis brossé les dents ce matin.
Pas avec Colgate Total.
Excusez-moi...
Pens...
Non non.. Est-ce que je vais me faire chier
dans la rue, moi ?!
Et ton cul, il est propre ducon ?!
Avec ta cravate de merde !
Tu veux savoir si
tu vas retourner avec ton ex ?
Envoie "EX" au 81212.
Elle est morte.
Ca commence par des démangeaisons
et des sensations de brûlure,
savez-vous ce que c'est ?
Ce sont des mycoses vaginales.
Non, je ne veux pas me cacher !
Tu sais...
J'ai des mycoses vaginales.
D'ailleurs, ça me gratte.
Mais tu sais...
Ca peut arriver à tout le monde.
Mais... mais...
Attends !
Ca me brûle vraiment, hein !
J'pense que
je l'ai un peu fragilisé.
Avec la 4G, c'est l'accès a
tout Internet en un instant.
Euh... J'y vais ?
Non non...
Allez !
On dit que j'y vais !
(Dégouts)
Moi, j'aime ma banque.
Moi, je m'en bats les couilles
de ma banque.
Je rêve d'une banque...
(Rires)
(Hués)
Allez putain...
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle
Sous-titres réalisés para la communauté d’Amara.org